welcome to this video playing his oka 88
from China I guess yep in a king's
indian or is interesting I'm very often
get bad positions because I don't know
the opening too well but it leads to
interesting play yeah the Sun now is
place 95 anyway interesting mostly they
play 92 and this specific gam set up ok
now probably ninety six hour he will
play now I can grab here my has played
Bishop to a three very very early and
I'm not so sure about that that's really
great can I go here yeah let's try that
getting in 94
today overlooked something
just just just just a moment if I go d5
can he take on d5 maybe maybe he can but
not really i can take with the night and
94 coming her camera let's let's do that
I was thinking King age eight I think I
don't think this was too bad but I mean
94 no 94 m I don't don't see the problem
come on it should win material I mean
even know okay I thought he would would
be inclined to sacrifice something okay
then I I just bolts to this guy's must
be good for black herring I want a pong
and I got this this big center here
unless I'm losing something directly
like it's an excellent shape him just
from when nervous I should really play
King h8 next and I d6 bone and edition
is also basically lost yeah of course he
needs to he needs to do something
yeah the long diagonal this is the only
thing that may be wide can try like
Bishop b2 and somehow but then there's
so much stuff on the long diagonal don't
really don't really see how the shutdown
work yeah this time I had seen you can
take here what just look like Queen to
c7 covering that but this puts yet
another piece in this this mentioned
long diagonal as though I still don't
see what should happen
defending with counter counter threats
okay this is a good move that I hadn't
seen ready if I go nite b 3 i'm not just
taking this this thing on okay getting
out of this tag no no no just trying to
take here and take only six claiming
that two pawns should be enough and then
Bishop g7 back try to keep it simple
I can maybe also take with the Queen on
e6 after luke t for this Bishop e3 check
yeah that's may be an interesting
additional point okay if I know take
them in 95 maybe Jack come on keep it
simple and then just take you some
what's the threat is there threat may be
94 simply 93 Bishop f2 if we go screen
see three edges play Bishop g7 yeah or
is there is there something better can
give this check down but ok come on that
that's the easiest way to do it check
check yeah this is saying but I have 95
this yeah that's that's now an
interesting point this is an activation
of the rook can i play it in an active
manner giving up this
time warning hmm ok let's play it
actively don't want to check play
passive I've got my yet yes no yeah
that's a way to lose this amazing
amazing after this I mean this was a
total joke of a game and I overlooked
light is six great remarkable check now
with total joke I mean I was I had
multiple ways to win this really like
could basically play whatever only not
what I did the eyes with this a six
trick I don't know maybe you just
blunders and was lucky
96 m remarkable really now even rookie 3
is winning check I do I don't get
anything in this game now I'm promoting
with the check check
check-check
check game drunk yeah and what the heck
is happening in this game I mean I
completely overlooked 96mm just the
absolute and he overlooked it as well
yeah amazing really amazing wow I can
they can you play whatever like this
covering 95 and it's gone basically
black is winning out of the opening here
after this black black is just totally
winning doesn't matter of precision I
mean I didn't play it very precisely but
black was winning all the time I guess
our computers on Jack plus three plus
four plus five whatever and here there's
probably even something quicker there
should be three STI Africa are because
of the week back rank yeah check that's
true check because of this check no
that's that sets even clearer yeah ok
this is it to the total endgame when I
just take the playbook f6 and we
blundered this chap blunder these two
times check check yeah and this is this
this whole endgame is also totally
totally weird yeah you played this this
crazy move yeah and i'm not sure if it
was also and this is this is funny motif
that this pawn is actually promoting
this is a draw the computer tells me
check now because of technical means i
can stop the pony I didn't see that I
went I went forward with this 18 seconds
yeah and it here I mean I didn't get
anything I play he played this jack yeah
now he took here instead of just going
back nothing happens and after this I'm
promoting I'm just winning of course
jack but I have seven seconds which is
not not really a lot i mean it's it's
doable but i was so shaky from this work
he came oh my okay thanks for watching